the clever thing with Russian conspiracy
theories and and disinformation is
there's always like a Tiny Seed of Truth
in it
[Music]
if you're a journalist just don't engage
because
once you start doing that you find
yourself doubling down and the danger of
that is that you stop seeing the other
side you become so convinced in your own
argument and so convinced with your
investigation that it must be the one
thing that you all you're fighting
hundreds of people on Twitter about that
you don't look for the other side and
that's the most dangerous thing about
this moment of polarization for all of
us I think is that we stop questioning
and to get to the truth you've got to
keep you've got to keep doing that as
much as possible
that changes again with the fog of War
um which is something we you know we've
all seen recently with Ukraine for me uh
I I really sort of realized how hard it
was to get anything anywhere near the
truth in the war in Syria
so I was based in Beirut for for quite a
lot of it and we were all sort of a lot
of the journalists were based in
countries around Syria trying to report
on Syria as much as possible but it was
one of the hardest Wars to report on
because most of the time we couldn't get
in so we were sort of stuck on the
borders of Syria trying to give an
impression of what was happening talking
to people who are coming out but the
people who are coming out are obviously
from one section of society they're the
ones desperate to get away from Assad
but you're not hearing the other side
you could go in if you went
um with you know that they would give
you permission but then you're on a
government tour basically you're seeing
what they want you to see not very much
else and occasionally we would be able
to go in for like a two-day raid or
something or a three-day raid but you
knew that every minute you were there it
was so dangerous and you would you know
there were dangers of kidnap killing in
a way that normally if you wear a press
jacket that wouldn't happen here you
would have to hide you'd have to take
off anything that would identify you as
being from the West make sure you didn't
have any money on you you know totally
clean your mobile phone before you went
in in case you were sort of captured and
you'd have to go in disguised and you
couldn't be there for very long which
makes it really hard to try to show the
world what's happening
so we became quite reliant on
effectively citizen journalism on seeing
what people were sending out now we'd
sort of already seen some of this in the
Arab Spring where
citizen journalism and the social media
had probably their best moment you know
that every time we have arguments now
about anonymity online for example you
know the one shining example of when it
really worked was the Arab Spring
because in countries with oppressive
regimes you know places like Egypt
people could take on a blogger you know
any any name as a blogger or a Twitter
handle and they could keep sending out
visions of the you know the sort of
things that they were experiencing they
could put out the truth in a way that
those regimes had never really allowed
before they have such censored media
sense of social media often and suddenly
it was breaking through and we sort of a
lot of journalists this became the
moment when they realized that this is
actually quite powerful you know rather
than us going in trying to understand
the country in two days you've got
people who've lived through it all their
lives telling you what's happening
showing you the nuance and it's an
incredibly important tool but quite soon
but before the Arab Spring was even over
we also realized it was a very dangerous
one because there a couple of people who
a lot of journalists followed who they
quoted who turned out not even you know
they weren't even there you know there's
a guy in the Philippines who was sort of
pretending to be I don't know why you do
that but people do and you have to be
aware of that all the time so you know
whenever I was in Egypt I'd have to I
would arrange to meet in secret places
some of these Anonymous bloggers just to
make sure that they were you know they
were absolutely authentic
um and just to check their credentials
so that from then on you knew you could
rely what they were on what they were
saying
um but in Syria that just wasn't
possible so there was suddenly you were
getting more more information online and
on Twitter and on social media than you
ever had before from a war that was
taking place as it happened as it was
unfolding you were seeing bombs you were
seeing
um Barrel bombs going through the sky
you were seeing people injured you were
seeing children sort of covered in
wounds in a way that we very rarely had
got to see before you know an entire
cross-section not just what one media
organization had managed to capture but
then how do you know if it's true
Russia was obviously very active in the
Syrian war and Russia has always been
very good at disinformation and they
immediately sort of cottoned onto this
so although the world had changed in the
past they'd sort of used media control
to try to control their message they
suddenly realized that you could you
could do the same thing with social
media by putting out your own Bots who
were putting out their version of what
was happening using images you know from
previous Wars or you know images that
had been doctored but nobody could
really call it up because it was the
same as any other citizen journalist
that they were relying on so what what
do you do they also started campaigns to
discredit people describe you know if
you were seeing what looked like a
chemical weapons attack they'd say it
was fake it had been put on this was
actors they dressed up they're all alive
and well
um they the Russians also often do sort
of false flag operations which is
fascinating and dark and horrendous
where they'd start to say we're getting
reports that Rebels are going to carry
out an attack on themselves
and you always know where they're going
to attack because they start putting
this information out they start telling
you that they're going to attack
themselves in order to blame the
Russians and then lo and behold a day
later they've been hideously attacked
there are lots of people dead and the
Russians sort of say we told you they
were going to do this uh and you you
know where where does the truth lie how
do you begin to make sense of that
um one of the great things that came out
of the Syrian War though and if you
haven't already I'm sure many of you
have but
um do follow bellingcat which uh Elliott
Higgins a great guy who was sort of sat
at home in Leicester I think and just
had like this amazingly
um amazing Fascination for for different
types of weapons and started geolocating
some of the images that were coming out
and started looking at
almost doing forensic
investigations on what you could see to
try to work out if they're authentic and
he's been incredibly successful so more
recently in the Ukrainian War we've sort
of seen
some of the images that the Russians
have put out and bellingcat who sort of
had this wonderful service you can sort
of follow what they're doing they've
been able to identify the images they're
using are from the Chechen wall you know
from a totally different place in a
different time and they haven't even
bothered changing like the metadata that
goes with it so it's sort of it's
incredibly obvious they also through
that through the Syrian War managed to
sort of perfect their skills of being
able to identify just by looking at the
image find clues of where they are
whether it could whether it could
possibly be authentic and in Ukraine
it's come in really handy where there
have been moments for example where the
Russians have said we we didn't carry
out those attacks this must just be the
ukrainians making it look like we've
blown things up or we've we've killed
civilians we haven't been killing
civilians and they've sort of shown
bodies that have and they you can
identify the time by the fact that some
of the buildings around them have
already been blown up and so it must
have been after the Russians came in not
before you know so they've been able to
challenge them every time they put out a
narrative they go away and investigate
all the all the facts that they've put
in there and what you can identify from
the pictures and whether you can just
completely challenge their narrative
and and that that has proved to be
completely invaluable
learning how to make sense of Russian
disinformation is probably the the most
important skill for all of us to
navigate the modern world because this
isn't going away and it's spreading from
you know War but beyond that too I mean
I did an investigation for the times a
little while ago
um I mean how many people here got the
AstraZeneca vaccine during covert
most of the yeah great most of the
country I think did but
um just as it was being it was getting
to the final stage of testing and it was
about to be approved uh I I had
investigated a lot of Russian stuff
during the brexit funnily enough
um and I had lots of contacts around
that world and that people were getting
in touch with me saying the Russian
government was paying the money to
spread disinformation around the world
and on social media and making it look
like it was coming from sort of
influences and people who were just
tweeting about this stuff basically and
it's going to sound stupid because it is
but it becomes a meme as a result of
that and it gets spread but calling the
AstraZeneca vaccine the monkey vaccine
um I absurd I know but the clever thing
with Russian conspiracy theories and and
disinformation is there's always like a
Tiny Seed of Truth in it so they were
using
um you know they were using a particular
type of Vector in the experiments which
sort of uh originated from a chimpanzee
I think uh and the Russians sort of
clocked onto that and it was the only
difference between their vaccine and
this vaccine and they wanted to be able
to discredit hours so that they could
sell more of theirs so they jumped on
that turned it into an entire
um I mean like some of the stuff they
wanted to spread it's kind of hilarious
when you look at it they said they
docked it all posters from films they
sort of had
um these sort of gods you know these
sort of um huge King Kong sort of images
of people you know this is what you'll
turn into once you have the vaccine they
have hilarious cartoons of sort of like
people walking in to get a vaccine and
then uh they even had videos so and all
sort of like almost Hulk like bursting
out of their clothes and turning into
monkeys and then going off I mean like
it's absurd it is absolutely absurd but
if you see something as ridiculous as
that chances are you might you might
pass it around
and none of those memes were really
meant for us they weren't supposed to be
in spread in Europe or they were going
to be spread in Europe just as a way of
sort of showing everybody that everyone
should be calling it The Monkey vaccine
and the moment you get that name out
there people will refer to it as that
even if they don't believe it and then
slowly that's how people start to see it
and that's that's toxic enough but their
campaigns were massively focused on
South America
the Middle East and Southeast Asia
because those were the markets they'd
identified who hadn't already bought
vaccines and who were in the market for
some and if they could discredit ours
they could sell theirs there and you
know in in the run-up to getting a
vaccine we were all so worried about
saving lives you know not many people
were stopping and thinking about just
how big a business this is I mean that
is worth billions every time you get a
contract for a country it's worth an
absolute fortune and also it was just an
incredibly dangerous thing to be doing
at the time
um you know exactly when we already had
so much vaccine hesitancy and so many
conspiracy theories around the vaccine
to be spreading this just to gain more
business
and you know the moment that story went
out we put it out on the front page of
the times within a couple of hours you
know I was getting phone calls directly
from the guy in charge of the Russian
direct investment fund and the Kremlin
came out putting out statements about
this story because it mattered to them
that their thing had been exposed and
they didn't want to lose tracks They had
and they needed to be able to still make
you know make a claim to sort of their
vaccine being better and they needed to
look credible which very rarely happens
normally when you put out a story about
a conspiracy theory they just don't even
acknowledge it they they look away but
this was one that really mattered and
one of the things I learned from that
was just looking at the markets where
they were really specializing where they
were sort of focusing South America the
middle east Southeast Asia
we don't look at what the Russians are
doing there very often you know we look
at what RT does here a lot we call it
out whenever we can
and I think since the Ukrainian Invasion
there's sort of been this sense that oh
look the whole world now recognizes what
Russia does the whole world is
supporting Ukraine and that's just not
true you know we've seen a lot of
countries are sort of struggling to to
pick a side they don't particularly want
to and quite a few of them are still
sort of quite supportive of Russia and
if you look at those those countries if
you look at sort of RT in South America
for example it's fascinating it's
incredibly effective it has a huge
audience it's putting out messaging that
is being believed all the time
if you look at the Chinese media they
have people all of their sort of State
TV all their journalists who are in
Ukraine covering the war are embedded
with Russian soldiers they're seeing the
Russian side of what's Happening they're
not they're not particularly sympathetic
to the Ukrainian side because they're
sort of covering it very much from the
Russian perspective and I think there is
a danger
and this goes back to what we were
saying earlier about confirmation bias I
think with Ukrainian War if you're
trying to understand what's happening on
the ground we've got to be very aware of
Russian disinformation and the sort of
messages that the Russians were have
been spreading for years now all over
the world and how that will affect
people's perceptions but also our own
confirmation bias and I think
I've I've sort of noticed it more than
any other War I think so if you know
Afghanistan and Iraq they were
controversial Wars so journalists who
were out there covering it you know
unlike sort of Syria they could be a bit
more questioning they would they would
have reports about what British soldiers
weren't doing right you know they they
were always questions being asked with
Ukraine and it's not necessarily that
we're trying to spread disinformation
but I think there is just sort of a
genuine sense of sympathy and and the
reporting as a result does get shaped by
that and I don't think we're sort of
we're very keen at the moment to sort of
say the whole world is on side and the
whole world sees through Russia and I
don't think we're thinking enough about
what's happening in the global South in
places like South Africa India and
Pakistan South America where that
message just isn't really cutting
through
and we should also think about it in
terms of what we know about the war
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas